forecast on 8 news now rain on Sunday
for the first of the year now more
showers popping up on a radar good to
see this shot again I know I have nine
Tower cams but I love showing the tower
cams actually have some raindrops this
one we had some earlier tonight and
still continues at the sour 52 degrees
our official high for the day take cool
day today five below normal 38 was our
morning star at the record 69 degrees
that was back in 1981. now on to our
temperatures outside let's start off
this time in the Northwest part of the
valley 44 for you Cincinnati Hills 43
right now for Summerlin 47 for the Lakes
how about Aliante 43 for you Sunrise
Manor 49 51 for Green Valley Whitney
Ranch included in Rhodes ranch Mountains
Edge 46 Henderson I want to leave you
guys out currently 45 degrees it's 11
o'clock hour outside of town 42 for
Pahrump up there Northeast Clark
Mesquite you're at 42 as well 52 down
river in Laughlin we're in the low 40s
also for Boulder City so going on a
satellite and radar look at that one
wave passing through now we're seeing
some clearance just to the west but
still some shower activity coming in
from Canada we talked about that
rainfall that was I should say in
California we saw that rainfall in
central California now it's moving its
way past the Sierras and moving towards
us so still more rain more showers still
possible overnight there's the
atmospheric River not directed towards
us just yet but this next storm is going
to dive down tap into the more of that
moisture again and send into California
and eventually us to win slight chances
return on Wednesday but the better
chances you can see is really going to
be on Thursday widespread Chances with
also more Mountain snow look at this is
Wednesday or Thursday by 11 A.M midday
afternoon hours too going to miss some
slick roads probably sticking around
also off and on some hit and miss
showers expected also for Thursday
evening so our better chances for
rainfall this week high probability that
this is what to expect your weather
impacts Mountain snow high probability
no worries about any flooding here all
right but we do also have some breezes
that will pick up a little bit not
expecting any of those strong gustier
winds 40 degrees your forecast overnight
showers again are possible while you're
sleeping could see it for the first part
of the morning commute light Breeze is
expected overnight your high tomorrow 54
degrees a mix of sun and clouds a cool
day tomorrow still below normal look at
these numbers here across the valley in
the low to mid 50s from Centennial Hills
to Green Valley to Aliante outside of
town cooler for you out in Pahrump 51.
52 for Boulder City so it's your most
accurate eight day forecast looking
ahead better chances like we said
Thursday slide chances Wednesday a brief
break Friday Saturday and that looks
like Sunday and then those chances could
return again for next week we hope so